you know I'm actually perfect for the
role of Catwoman because I actually
speak cat um for example um feed me is
and uh let's play um let's see oh don't
talk to my mouse toy Wow Wow they're
very territorial creatures um let's see
what else is there oh here's um help
help you've trapped me in the washing
machine so ever dude knows that and here
is oh my god please take me to the vet
right now what's it all for Alfred
what's it all for I mean I lost Rachel
maybe I should just hang up the mask and
Gowland
call it a good Ron that's cock ik tease
Oh bollocks
you are Gotham City's destiny and it's
time that you started acting like an
adult and dressed up as a bat what am i
Rachel Rachel
Rachel's Kentucky Fried Chicken 11 herbs
and spices in the deep fryer Jesus al
forgive me a minute two more you can
mourn when you're dead now why don't I
cheer you up with one of my horror
stories about raping the Burmese jungle
in search of the blood diamonds well I
guess in the end
come from the fact that she did truly
love me
okay look at that a letter from Rachel
let me see that hey dear Bruce I don't
look hey Donnie uh I'm a little nervous
about my Bain impression why is that
well I don't have the voice down quite
right I mean I remember even in the
movie even though he had the mask he
somehow projected more than anyone else
in the entire film okay no actually it's
okay someone showed me how to do the
perfect Bain impression really who you
know Ian Sinclair the voice actor yeah
bet Ian Sinclair no but I know someone
who stalked him and before they hold him
away in the police car he told me that
you knew Claire told him how to do the
perfect Bain impression
well how okay you start off by doing
your Sean Connery oh my name hunter I
wonder sir you do shaking that Shh all
right all right now you do Sean Connery
giving birth to Adam Sandler would you
be talking all right good
now you take your hands you do the ninja
gaiden thing and then you just place it
over your mouth and suddenly the follow
shoes yeah that's incredible
I know try it try it okay let me try
okay I have got those ready okay okay no
no this is a kind of mistake
all right you can't just put it over
like this you have to do the ninja
gaiden hands try to get oh oh all right
I know right it's unbelievable you
something you like transform it
something like your muscle found in
every
you should shave your head give me a
spigot edit the tongue tutor eyes Gotham
is feeding them false hopes to poisoned
our soul it will begin here this is an
Arby's of course why is it an Arby's
yeah I mean it's not exactly a very
secret headquarters have you ever eaten
at an Arby's now have you all know it's
a great nobody has who wants to pay
$5.00 for crappy deli meat in a
cafeteria about the 70s forgot to
prepare for the gathering of all of
Gotham super bones
we're about to begin oh cool I'm a
crippled man now Alfred beaten and
destroyed but being is out there and I
have to stop him
you cut why not
what if I told you I had a secret letter
from Rachel a letter than I ate
a letter in what she says she didn't
love you
and I've been letting you destroy
yourself for these eight years because I
thought I was protecting you by letting
you pummel supervillains by dressing up
as a bhakti let's say that's the ravings
of a mad scientist I'm leaving you
master wife what why I can't watch you
throw your life away
but wait then in a scene earlier you
just say I will never give up on you and
now you're saying I'm giving up on you
master wedding so your time of the month
or something or goodbye master wait and
I'm keeping the jewelry figures he leave
on laundry day
our suburban brothers are you Rabine
Ra's al Ghul present Joker present
scarecrow ready whoo The Rock the world
see what true evil are beige is capable
fiercely could we had just gone to the
sewers oh that would be an improvement
but I must admit though curly fries all
careless and they tasty then you're
gonna love my knuckle sandwich oh ma how
did you find me using my super duper
detective skills I managed to locate
when no other cop could by the way if
you need help finding any other super
villains I'm here I don't know he's you
anyway
hard to find me bad mom drives most of
them but I was going to give this live
speech about the shadows for training
you but you just can't let it happen
zipper like that long go to waste
oh oh throw him in that side I can't I
crawled out of you prepare yourselves
top we'll be good
I'm sure our Sun rises why then because
I love these breakfast sucks but Sir
what about the curly fries they won't be
done for watch out oh the special sauce
is done the croissants lying ashes that
you have my permission to run that was
the stupidest line I've ever know what
are they arguing about
apparently we're getting close to the
scene where we reveal all the
supervillains together but I guess you
oh man Donny
you have a disagreement about how we're
going to do it okay forget it forget it
it's not gonna happen there's no way it
can work
it's the stupidest idea I've ever heard
we're not doing the super villain
shuffle I'm also cool and I'm here to
say no inflection in your voice
is they okay with the week of shadows on
the Gotham all I am several identities
all of them don't have Harvey Dent in my
face of thing
my evil motivation makes little sense I
wasn't nice guy but now drained
determine my feature on the back of
change the hata to can turn on the flip
of a dime boy I tell you this deal is
getting worse all the time
I am dr. crane totally insane and I only
have a few lines in the movie so next
now this is a story all about how
my frown got flipped-turned upside down
and i'd like to take a minute don't go
too far i'm gonna tell you a little
story about how I got these scars my
daddy was a drinker my wife she liked to
gamble my dog the plastic surgeon please
stop me if I ramp my plan sir so detail
is like a tea into the future I'm a
ballbusting fan bashing gangster Manoj I
quit the reason you shouldn't quit it's
because you have so much potential still
untapped how would you know you never
let me write what I want I'm just trying
to make both our visions come to life
I'll tell you what if you let me rewrite
the ending I'll come back why what's
wrong with my ending that man should not
be an alien from the planet SycE alright
alright alright alright how about go
along with your ending let's do it let's
do it you won't change it or anything
No alright let's do it alright awesome
now first thing we got to do is just do
the climax so does
the world's greatest prison yes my truck
friend well there is no prison on the
planet that can keep the world's
greatest detect help me fight off the
guards there's no guards the world's
greatest prison doesn't have any guards
nope
okay well help me dig a hole there's
already a boom the world's greatest
prison already has a hole in it okay all
right well we will be the first to get
out of there actually someone already
has small child so let me get this
straight
the world's greatest prison has no
guards a giant hole in it
let's broken out of by a little boy
little girl little girl and somehow this
is supposed to hold me kind of all right
let's just practice all right all right
that's a five
okay they say we can get them to see
just about any watch hard aboard gar gar
gar gar gar gar gar gar gar gar bar
Donny hmm what is this that's the link
for the little boy singing the national
anthem a wig cuz I don't see hair it
looks like somebody left a swim cap on
the stove you know that's how I did it
did I just it's gonna look great on
camera you gotta look at it's gonna be
like wow that's a boy you smelled it
smell it it smell it very nice the
bottom why is that you're gonna put it
on it's gonna look great on camera
everyone's gonna be like wow that's a
little boy not that you're not very very
feminine okay look there is no way I am
wearing
whose broad stripes and bright stars
I've got it all wrong
maybe that bill still Hogan decency left
in the world and this child this
innocent child has shown me the way
but the lice of a manager
Oh narcos drug for her account about
where this hi yes I finally made it my
crime rate and you'll be sure to tell
someone to save us right of course my
good friends
unless of course for some reason I have
to sacrifice myself of a good the city
giving away Who I am so I totally have
to thank my death at which case you're
unbelievably screwed I'll try not to let
that happen
citizens of Gotham I have a nuclear
thing in the bag that's time - its Mary
six months prepare for the same thing
you've got about chaos in the previous
two movies I want a la hey when I
decided you've all hit rock bottom
then I will blow your urban her back why
don't you just blow us up now because I
want to just do it
that's the way you want it or just blow
you oh I'm here um hold on I can't do it
I'll tell you what let me get to taxi
get a few hundred miles away from here
I've destroyed out of the bridge that
shot myself in the foot here let's just
keep the game game come on come on I
think I saw some of you coming near the
ends amber uh everybody okay
huge wants to see my daddy's halftime
show somebody knocked out the guards but
who
God man thank God you saved this for
falling into the ice what's your plan
did you really think the ice would meet
you they said without your design man
what you think I would hold you anyway
you're costing just do me a favor and
like that player oh now you want to put
fire on the incredibly sensitive I don't
like my enemies no I mean gasoline all
the way across the ice and upwards
oh my god Friday what miss me no but
holy water I broke your baby back one of
the inmates hetero strained me out oh
right a friggin wrote what I'll say my
divers planet right there who else it is
a bush ups push ups you are invalid for
me to use weight wisdom you want to
twist I have a twist
oh hey that woman I barely know who is
led to it I'm actually rather Bulls
daughter what yeah I hated my father so
much but after you killed him I decided
to avenge his death that doesn't make
any sense he wanted to make even less
sense
I'm also rich doors that's right you
left me to die now it's time to return
the favor
well there's not a pleasant surprise
for I'm Rachel's twin sister Raquel does
oh that's right I was hired to work for
babe but now my second life is having
second thoughts
well isn't that quite a turn Hey look at
that bit right from the Sun kid
that's right well I really Robin I'm so
confused
oh Jenny buddy have a flowchart so
Selena is just one of a thousand cloves
Bain is just another one of my multiple
personalities and the mine was the scene
of the crime the whole sad still don't
know how to slough fits into all that
David Bowie was awesome though David
Bowie wasn't there thinking I will get
it backwards to see it oh you know I
think it would have been a lot better if
we did introduce all the plot twists in
the last five minutes oh good let's just
wrap this up let's do it
wait wait nothing good hey can we just
all right let's get that makeup off yeah
oh hey Quinn not again Batman
the bombs about to go off what are we
gonna do I had to sacrifice myself for
the good of the city y-you can't
you've given these people all you have
not everything not yet why why would you
sacrifice yourself
because you either die a hero or live
long enough to see yourself become the
villain I am the hero and the government
deserves but the one they need for I am
the terror that blends in the night I am
the very model of a modern major-general
I am The Walrus I am what I am and
that's all that I for I am bat Jesus and
the bat shall lay down with the ball
Gold speed bat Jesus God's me okay so
tell me about this ending you really
really want to do well it's always
bothered me at the end
Alfred looks up and you see something
then Nolan just gives it away we
actually see Bruce Wayne and Selena
together we don't need that it should be
ambiguous you know Alfred looks up he
smiles
what is Alfred see we hold that shot and
the audience just keeps guessing the
whole time you know it's more powerful
that way
you know I think I like that so you hold
on Alfred you never actually see if he's
seeing Bruce you never see what he see
exactly I think it's a good idea you
know what let's do this
let's make this happen yes thank you I'm
really excited about this I always
wanted to see a more subtle ending to
the spell something that works in here
the brain this time around you won't see
what Alfred sees with your eyes instead
you'll see it with your mind okay okay
we get the ending right there buddy just
the way you want it grapes
oh wait there's dialogue oh it's nothing
like we can keep carded just that
spontaneity mind inside the stuff you
like but it's doing idea oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah no no it's still your idea I
promise you you never see what Alfred
sees okay good all right and uh where's
the cue card gonna be I'm gonna be
holding the cue card right over there
just as soon as I say action you read
right off it all right as long as we
don't see what Alfred is see I promise
you do not see what Alfred is seeing
why
Marcel Wayne I can't believe it's you
sitting right there across from me and
with Selina Kyle who woulda thunk it you
two free and together at last
oh happy day wait
motherfuck yeah he's right that was a
lot better
all right now time to edit out his
commentary at the end motherfucker I
can't believe you is script it's so
festive calm motherfucker
you just wait you but I mean with your
crew shoe salesman so Steph a shot bitch
you
one of the few downsides of course to
being an online film maker is you do
have bills to pay but fortunately I have
my wife's income to help out with that
which I'm sure a lot of people five-fold
with I just wants a letter I do die to
pray we represent sweet filmmakers
everywhere blah blah blah we saw be kind
rewind FERS yada yada yada we will make
you pay better
okay it doesn't matter well here I'm
gonna show you a little bit more about
the perks of filmmaking by showing you
all about lighting now these look great
I forgot to edit the scene all that crap
I forgot to komuz dialogue as bane oh
and the Joker's singing well I'm the
Joker now now this is the story all
about how don't go from something
there's no question that demo reel
productions is doing far superior work
than anything that's in cinema today so
leave a comment down below to let us
know which film you like to see double
reel do next
you